Let's start.
So, today is the seventh lecture
things are going to
start getting more interesting cuz we're
going to talk a bit about sequence
modeling and transformers.
And also specially how they are
related to robotics. So, as a quick
recap
we've been looking mostly so far at
reactive policies. Where we've taken
like a single observation
OT
feed it through our policy
to get an action.
And in principle like this this is like
works in
in in theory but it breaks very easily
in the real world
because one snapshot usually doesn't
kind of cover all the information
about the state. So,
there is kind of like one two two issues
right? So, like one of them is like
memory with this kind of reactive
policies we might not know
what we have done like you know a few
seconds ago how what decisions we have
made or how the world was looking like
which might be relevant when we are like
driving an icy road with an autonomous
car.
Or from just like a single image
observation it might not be
possible to understand how pedestrians
are moving
you know in the scene so that we don't
run them over
if you know it's just like a static
image it's very difficult to estimate
any velocities or motion.
And there's also another issue of
action smoothness right?
So, our kind of one step prediction
models so far usually have been
predicting just a single action for the
next time step right? And
this can often in the real world lead to
kind of like jerky
trajectory that are like non smooth cuz
like every like every decision is kind
of like different and so you can like
get list this kind of jerky um
oscillating um
behavior sometimes. And so um today
we're going to talk about um some fixes
we can do to address these issues, uh
which involve um sequence modeling on
transformers.
And that's what we're going to cover
today.
Um
and so
uh
what it means is that um as I just said,
right? Like just having a a single frame
is usually like not not uh sufficient
cuz in practice in robotics we are not
operating in an MDP, but in like a
partial partially observable
um MDT MDP. Um and so to really
understand the state, we kind of need to
reason uh over the history or the the
trajectory,
uh so like a sequence of observations
and and actions.
Um and
um
and you can see also here, right? Like
this is the
kind of the trajectory probability
formula we've been using uh through the
lecture. Um and you see that how the
policy we are um
uh modeling this is just this kind of
like one-step uh policy uh
model like single-step and reactive.
Um and this is kind of like a
fundamental mismatch between um
like the world is really like
sequential, but like our policy like is
isn't.
Um so the natural question then is like
um
what if we just model the whole
trajectory directly instead of just like
the the next
uh action.
Uh so how do we how can we model these
sequences, right? Uh and the most
general way to think about this is um
through the lens of auto-regressive
models.
Um
and the the key insight here is um that
um
and this is just kind of the the pro it
comes from like uh the property of the
probability, um the chain rule, right?
Um so it tells us that for um
any joint distribution, uh no matter how
complex or high-dimensional,
we can decompose this into product of
conditional distributions.
And so,
this means that we can
get the probability of the entire
sequence
just as the probability of the first
element times the probability of the
second element and so forth
autoregressively.
Um
Now, the the key the key
question we're going to like cover in in
this
lecture is how do we actually model
these these conditional
conditionals.
Because if your sequence is like very
high-dimensional,
you know, it might be a high-resolution
video or like a complex robot
trajectory, then this will become like
very long, very very like difficult, and
we can't just use like a big lookup
table.
So, the first logical tool that was kind
of like invented to handle these
conditionals
are recurrent neural networks or RNNs.
The idea
is very simple. You have like a hidden
state
that summarizes everything you've been
so you've seen so far, and then you
update it recurrently as new inputs
arrive, which is great as now you can
handle variable length inputs.
In practice, they have three kind of
serious issues or failure modes. The
first one is long-range dependencies.
So, to get information from step one to
step 100, you have to propagate the
gradients through all 99 intermediate
steps,
and then those gradients typically
explode or vanish.
And
LSTMs kind of helped this, but didn't
fully solve it.
Then,
you have the parallelization issue. It's
RNNs are very difficult to parallelize
due to their autoregressive nature. And
the third one is the bottleneck problem.
So, all your history gets compressed
into a fixed-size
um
uh vector, um no matter how long your
sequence is, right? So, uh there is kind
of um uh
a fundamental um
information bottleneck that you can't
hack your way around
out of.
And so, RNNs RNNs get you uh part of the
way there, um
but uh the limitations uh are, you know,
um difficult uh in practice to to scale.
Um and by now, most of you are are
probably familiar with this um
um with the Transformers paradigms, but
I will be give like a brief recap um so
everybody's on the same page. Um so,
instead of uh recurrence um in
Transformers, uh we use attention. And
the key property of attention is uh that
it gets you uh O(1) uh uh uh hop path
length between any two uh positions in
the sequence. Um looking at the um
diagram, this means that the the the
last word can attend to the first word
um uh directly in a in a single step,
right? With a direct connection, without
having to propagate through all the
intermediate um
words.
Um
and so, this simultaneously uh solves
all three problems we just described for
RNNs.
Um so, uh long-range dependencies are
now trivial. Uh training can be fully
parallelized because uh there is no
recurrence, and um there is no
fixed-size bottleneck uh because every
token has direct access to every other
uh token.
Okay, so how does it actually work? Um
so, now you have a sequence of tokens,
and for each uh
uh for each token, you want to compute a
new representation that incorporates um
uh information from the rest of
sequence. And so, the the question that
I um the attention operation tries to
solve is which part of the sequence
should you be looking at?
Um and so, essentially, this is what
what is being learned through through
attention, right? Um
So, you compute that relevance as the
the
dot product between a query vector
and a set of key vectors. Then you
normalize with a softmax, so it sums up
to one, and then you just take a
weighted average
of the value vectors, and that's that's
pretty much it.
Um and now, what
what the nice thing about this is that
you can think of this as kind of a
soft
differentiable dictionary lookup, where
instead of committing to a single
to to one entry as in a regular
dictionary, you're simultaneously
retrieving
all values and blending them together
weighted by how much each key matched
your query.
Um and so, because
all of these operations are fully
differentiable, now the model
doesn't just learn like
the representation, but also what is
kind of the optimal search strategy.
Um
Now, there is one subtle important issue
that in attention one needs to address
because um
because the attention is computing this
dot product between the tokens, it's
fundamentally a set operation,
and it treats all the inputs
without any notion of order. So, this
means
that the robot picked up the spoon and
the spoon picked up the robot would
produce identical
attention patterns
if you don't do something about this.
And the fix is to add positional
encodings, so you inject order
information directly into the token
representations.
Um and there are two main ways how you
can do this. The original approach from
the attention is all you need paper
is to just add a fixed vector to each
token embedding before it enters the
transformer.
Um, and it's pretty simple. It works
well. Um,
and it's absolute positional encodings.
Um, but there is kind of one uh
limitation that uh if um at test time
now you have longer sequences than the
ones you trained or you trained with um,
your um, like like that this will fail,
right? Cuz it's now out of distribution.
Um,
the second one is uh relative uh
positional encodings, which solve this
issue a bit more elegantly. So, instead
of encoding the absolute position in the
sequence,
um, you encode the distance between the
tokens.
Um, for example, it could be a bias that
um, you add directly to the attention
score. So, this means that um,
our example,
um, this uh the word spoon attending uh
to robot um,
will know that it's just like four steps
away regardless of of where in the
sequence they are.
Um, and crucially like this uh
generalizes then to to um, kind of
unseen lengths.
Um, and many of the modern uh foundation
models um, build upon um, kind of
similar extensions based on uh relative
distances.
All right.
Uh, now let's look uh at how the
original transformer um,
put all this together.
Um, so this model was designed for
machine transla- language translation.
Uh, so you have a source sentence um,
and then you want to produce a target
sentence in a different language. Um,
and then this kind of breaks down into
first understanding the uh source
sentence and then generating the target.
Uh, and hence they have this
encoder-decoder split. Um, the encoder
uses uh uh bidirec- bidirectional uh
self-attention. So, every token can see
every other token, past and future.
Um and this kind of makes sense because
you have um the full input available,
and you want to get your richest
possible representation
um
of each token.
And now for a decoder, uh and this is
very important, it uses uh causal uh
self-attention, where each token can
only attend to itself um uh and the
tokens that came uh before it. Um and
then we have um this this kind of like
triangular uh mask there um on the right
that is just setting uh future attention
uh scores to negative infinity uh before
softmax um so that they zero out. And
this is what makes auto-regressive
generation possible. At each step, you
only can uh can condition on what you
have already generated. Um
and then in the middle you can see the
cross-attention uh um
where uh
in the middle of the decoder, where uh
where is where kind of two the encoder
and decoder uh talk to each other. So,
the the decoder kind of um ask um given
what I've generated so far, uh what from
the source is relevant for me right now?
Um and so, this means that the queries
come from the decoder, and the keys and
values uh will come from the encoder.
Cool. Uh how do we train this? Um well,
uh very simple, we use something called
teacher forcing. The idea is that during
training, we don't care if the model
makes a mistake at a certain time step.
So, instead of feeding the model its own
potentially wrong prediction, uh we
always feed it the ground truth um of
the preceding tokens, and ask it to
maximize the likelihood of uh the next
correct token via cross-entropy loss.
Um and uh kind of the the nice thing
about about this whole whole operation
is that we just need one forward pass uh
to compute all T
all sequence losses with Transformer,
whereas with the RNNs we would need to
do one forward pass for for every
for every token.
All right, so before we can apply any of
this to robotics, we need to ask a more
basic question. What what is even a
token? How do you discretize your input
into
units that this Transformer can operate
on, right?
And so starting with language cuz that's
where Transformer originated,
we have two kind of like
obvious extremes, right? So
the first one is characters to use
characters, right? This would be a tiny
vocabulary
with sequences would be very large
and the model would need to learn like
very hard um
to to model all of them, right? And then
you have words on the other extreme
where
sequences would be like short
and each token would be meaningful,
but then
you know, you would have the issue of
like what do you do if you get an unseen
word, right? Like you might not be able
to represent it with your pre-trained
vocabulary.
And so neither extreme like works well
and ideally you will you want something
in the middle.
So units that are larger than characters
but smaller than words. And it can
handle unseen vocabulary
kind of gracefully
and keep sequence lengths manageable.
Because
the the attention operation is
quadratic, right? And so that's what sub
word sub word tokenization gives you. Um
So if you want the something in between,
typically there is we use this algorithm
called byte pair encoding or BPE,
uh is uh essentially a bottom-up
clustering approach Uh uh for for text.
Um so, the logic is very simple.
Uh as you see in the uh pseudocode here,
you start with the most built uh basic
building blocks, um
all unique characters in your data set,
and then you iteratively look for the
most frequent pairs of adjacent tokens
and merge them into a uh single new
token. Uh and you repeat this K times um
until you've built a vocabulary
uh of the size you want. And what
happens in practice is that common
subwords then get uh merged early
because they appear everywhere, uh and
then this keeps our sequence length
short,
uh which is again critical um for cuz a
transformer's memory usage is quadratic.
Um and the advantage of this is also
generalization because
uh now if you uh see a completely new
word um at test time, you can uh
probably break it down until like the um
uh until one common like uh subword
unit.
Um
into a sequence of kind of like uh known
subword unit.
Um here is a concrete example uh for one
sentence. Um the robots melted the
robots unbearably cheesy fondue.
Um and here in this animation, you can
see how BPE works uh in this single
sentence
uh and how um
like the subword uh tokens get merged.
Um and then the the result is that we
were we go from 54 characters compressed
down to uh 34 tokens.
So, like a 37% reduction, so that's
great.
Um one key detail um that you should
know about BPE is that the compression
factor scales with your uh corpus size.
So, the more data you train your BPE
tokenizer on, the more common patterns
will
get merged and the shorter your
sequences will become and therefore more
efficient your transformer.
Um and so modern LLMs trains on, you
know, kind of internet scale data. Uh
you know, maybe with a vocabulary of
like a 100k tokens, you'll get like
three or four times uh
kind of like compression rates compared
to to to this thing.
Um
All right.
So, how did we get from the original
transformer to scaling these two large
language models? Um I want to briefly
touch up on a few engineering decisions
that made them work at scale. The first
is um
um architectural simplification.
Uh so, modern LLMs like GPT drop the
encoder entirely and use decoder-only
models. It turns out that if you train a
a decoder uh on next next token
prediction,
um it's simpler to scale and with enough
data a causal decoder can just learn to
represent the context just as well as
the bidirectional encoder.
Um then the second one is extending BPE
to the byte level. So, instead of
operating on characters, you operate on
raw bytes.
Um which means your base vocabulary um
covers literally every possible input.
And I know I just told you in the
previous slide that BPE generalizes to
unseen words and that's true.
But with byte level BPE, you can also
generalize to let's say emojis
that we couldn't cover with the
pseudo algorithm I just showed you
before.
Um and then there are two kind of
engineering tricks or innovations that
made training on longer sequences
more practical.
One of them is Rope, Rotary Positional
Encodings, which is kind of an elegant
solution to the um
positional encoding problem, where
instead of adding the position vectors
to the embeddings, it rotate it rotates
the query and key vectors by an angle
proportional to their positions.
Um
Um so that um
the dot product uh
um depends only
on the relative distance between the the
tokens.
Uh and and not their absolute positions.
And then um Flash Attention solves the
memory bottleneck. Um so
um the standard attention uh requires
materializing the full um
n times n attention matrix, uh which is
uh n squared uh in memory consumption.
And then for very long sequences, this
becomes like a limiting factor. And then
with uh Flash Attention, this uh tiles
the computation into fast uh SRAM, so
that you never actually uh store that
matrix, getting your memory consumption
uh down to O of n with the same result.
So, let's take a step back and see how
people scaled up um Transformers and
what scale bought us. Um back in 2018,
uh with GPT-1, we were kind of still
very much in the pre-training plus
fine-tuning regime. Uh so, you train on
a billion tokens, but the model wasn't
actually useful for any specific task
until you did like supervised
fine-tuning um
on some narrow task uh data set.
Um then you move to uh GPT-2 in uh 2019,
so a year later.
Uh and then we um scaled the model uh
with 10 times the parameters uh and 10
times the tokens.
And then we started to see zero-shot
generalization, um
where the model starts being able to
perform tasks that it was uh not
explicitly told to do uh because it has
learned enough um kind of structure uh
of the world through text, right?
And then in GPT-3 in 2020 um with uh 175
billion parameters and 300 billion
tokens
um you have like this phenomenon with
where in-context learning uh emerged,
right? Uh so you give the model
a few examples in the prompt and then it
figures out like the pattern um of your
um context uh pairs and um is able to
apply this to new inputs uh without any
gradient updates.
Um and the surprising thing is that this
kind of emerges
uh or it it it just appeared as a
consequence of scale.
Um and this connects directly to um what
uh Rich Sutton uh called the bitter
lesson in 2019 where the argument is
quite simple um that he made. So it
basically states that if you look at the
history of AI over the past 70 years
then the methods that ultimately win are
not the ones um with the most clever
domain knowledge or the most carefully
hand-engineered features, but these are
the ones that actually scale with
compute. So like no matter if in chess
or in in speech recognition or go um in
every single case usually like um
handcrafted approaches were competitive
for a while, but then ultimately like
more general methods
uh with more compute eventually overtook
them.
Um and then this plot from the GPT-3
paper is kind of like a perfect
illustration for this where uh you can
see um that for uh this model with like
a uh just 1.3
billion parameters is like essentially
flatlining um no matter how many
examples uh you put in the prompt
um but then once you scale it to 175
billion parameters, um, the model
becomes a few-shot learner.
Uh, and again like this is, you know,
uh, not because somebody uh, engineered
it to do it so, but it just emerged uh,
through scale.
Um, and if this is true in language, um,
the question, you know, that the field
is uh, trying to answer today is also
uh, what emerges when you scale up robot
data, right?
Um,
so if scale is what matters, the next
question is, uh, how do you scale
optimally?
Uh, right? And so for a few years, um,
especially after uh, with GPT, the first
GPT models, um, the community seemed to
think that uh, just making the models
bigger uh, was the primary approach.
Uh, and this is what um, the Chinchilla
paper uh, from Hoffman et al. Um, worked
out uh, very precisely um, that this is
not the case.
Um, and the key finding here is that um,
given a fixed compute budget, uh, you
should scale your model size and your
data uh, in equal proportion.
Um,
so now if you look at the
uh, left plot over here, uh, you can see
um, the envelope for various model sizes
across different compute budgets, uh,
and at low compute budgets, the optimal
choice is actually a smaller model.
Right? So a 75 million parameter model
trained on to its optimal point sits on
the envelope uh, at low flops, uh, while
a 10 B model uh, trained with the same
compute budget would still be
undertrained and sitting above the
envelope.
Um,
and now in the center and and right
plots, uh, where we plot the scaling uh,
model size and training uh, against
compute, uh, we can see for example that
GPT-3 was actually undertrained, meaning
that it was too big um, for the amount
of tokens it was trained uh, on.
Compared to the optimal scaling uh,
frontier, which is um, this dashed green
line
that was derived in in the Hoffman
Chinchilla paper.
The paper also found out
that
you need roughly around 20 tokens per
parameter for compute optimality.
All right.
Um
So this slide shows you something
useful in practice that falls out of
this scaling laws.
And this is that you can actually
predict
how a larger model will perform before
you train it. So the idea is simple,
right? So before
you compute your entire you commit your
entire compute budget
to one big expensive run to train your
next GPT-6 model,
you first do a bunch of cheap small runs
at different model sizes
and compute budget and then you can kind
of like extrapolate what the performance
of your bigger bigger model will be.
And you can see that by kind of like
following the line the line of this
isoflop
plot.
And then
the
the right plot here
we plot the training tokens against the
model size
for
some different models and you can see
how
well the first GPT models were all under
trained, right? According to to the
optimal frontier.
And then kind of Llama 1, 2 and
Chinchilla
kind of like were more on the on the
they were on the more optimal compute
frontier.
And then you see um
the Llama 3 is like
way above the frontier, right?
So it it's trained on more
tokens than the compute optimal um
uh,
formula would suggest.
And the question is like, why did they
do this, right?
Um,
because
um, the motivation behind this is that
um, the compute optimal, um,
to be compute optimal is the right
strategy if you only care about the
training costs, but if you're going to
going to serve a model, um, to millions
of users, then you actually want a
smaller model that's cheaper to run at
inference, uh, even if that means, uh,
overtraining it slightly. And so, that's
why they made this this kind of
deliberate choice.
All right. Uh, so we've established
that, um, transformers are incredible
general-purpose sequence models.
Um, they, uh, we have LLMs, they they
scale predictively,
um, they have emerging capabilities, uh,
at scale. Uh, but for a robot, language
is only a half the story because, um,
for a robot, uh, it has to perceive, um,
the world, uh, to do decision-making,
right? So, the next natural question is,
uh, how can we extend our transformers
and LLMs
uh, to handle visual observations?
So, um, maybe you already remember this
from one homework assignment, but very,
like, uh, kind of recap uh, about image
tokenization.
Uh,
the kind of the key insight from the
vision, uh, transformer paper, uh,
sorry, from, uh, Alexey, uh, who I
overlapped with, uh, in Freiburg, um,
when he was a post doc there, by the
way.
And, uh, Lucas Beyer, uh, who will come
later in the course to give, uh,
in-person guest lecture, uh, is quite
simple. Um, so the idea is that you
treat image patches, uh, as tokens.
And so, you take your image, like, uh,
224 by 224, um, split it into your grid
of 16 by 16 patches, um, that gives you
196 patches, um, and then you flatten
each patch uh, each of these into a
vector, project this linearly,
and then you add a positional encoding
to tell the transform transformer where
in the image each patch patch came from.
And you're done.
Um, so now you have 196 tokens that
all look exactly like text tokens to the
transformer.
And um,
so essentially this is kind of similar
to the philosophy of the BPE we saw for
language, right?
We kind of try to find the right unit,
turn it into a vector, and then we let
the transformer figure out the rest.
And so for language,
kind of sub words was this unit, and for
images it's patches.
And because now the interface is
identical, you can start mixing
and matching these text and visual
tokens in the same sequence.
So,
um, so now we are at
this kind of elegant situation where
everything is a token,
but
this kind of raises the question if we
are just concatenate this this
this kind of image and text tokens in
the sequence together,
then the transformer has no idea
which one came from an image and which
one came from a text and how they
relate, right? And so for example,
ideally we would want our model to be
able to relate text tokens to um, let's
say the word apple with the visual
tokens
corresponding to let's say the bounding
box of an apple in the image, so that we
can later ask our robot to pick up an
apple and with a language instruction
that it kind of kind of understand what
we are telling it to do, right?
So,
so how can we teach the model to align
these two modalities?
One of the first answers to this
question came from OpenAI's CLIP model.
CLIP trains two separate encoders, hence
the two towers, a VIT for images and a
transformer for text. And then learns to
align them in a shared embedding space
using contrastive learning.
Um and so it's very simple. You have a
batch of N image-text pairs
scraped from the internet and then you
encode um
uh all of them into a N by N matrix
where you compute the cosine
similarities.
Um and then you have a kind of like a
temperature parameter to control the
entropy or the sharpness of your
distribution.
Um and um
yeah, and this way with this contrastive
alignment you get now visual visually um
visual representations that semantically
are aligned
with language. So now the image of a
apple and the word apple
will end up nearby in the embedding
space of this model.
Which is exactly what we wanted.
All right, sorry.
So
now this is another approach to aligning
vision and language but with a different
goal.
So CLIP was about learning a shared
embedding space between the two
modalities.
And now LLaVA, sorry, asks a different
question.
It asks, how do we inject visual
information directly into a pre-trained
LLM so that it can now reason over
images in the same way it reasons over
text.
Cuz with CLIP we didn't have like an
LLM, right?
Um and so the answer here is
to do early fusion. So you take your
image, you run it through a frozen clip
uh vision encoder,
um so you get your uh patch embeddings.
You pass those now through a uh small
trainable MLP connection layer um
um to fit them into the right
dimensionality, and then you just
prepend them um to your text token
sequence.
And now the LLM runs the standard
self-attention over the entire unified
sequence uh with no architectural
changes uh whatsoever.
Um and so
um here the key design choice is what is
uh frozen and what is trained. So, the
CLIP encoder stays frozen all the time,
um so you leverage all the pre-training
um and you're not touching this.
And then the MLP connector
uh learns how to project the visual
embeddings into the LLM's token space.
And then the LLM uh gets fine-tuned
uh on visual instruction data uh
teaching the model how to follow um
instructions in uh that are grounded in
images.
Then there is a third way um
um that world uh was uh
um that comes from the Flamingo paper um
called late fusion via gated
cross-attention.
Um and this is kind of contrasting to
the Lava's early fusion approach.
Um the key distinction is how and where
uh vision gets injected into the
language model. So, in Lava, the image
uh tokens are prepended uh to the text
sequence, and then everything goes
through the self uh to the same uh
self-attention.
Um Flamingo says uh what if instead of
keeping the LLM's uh self-attention uh
operating purely on text, um
uh can we inject visual information at
every layer uh via gated
cross-attention? And so, concretely,
what they uh proposed here is they um
keep the vision encoder frozen, and then
they
uh kind of compressed its output with a
perceiver resampler into a fixed size
set of keys and values.
And then at each layer of the LLM, there
is a new cross-attention block inserted
where the text tokens
act as queries and attend to those
visual keys and values.
And kind of the elegant part of the
whole approach is the tanh gate
cuz it's initialized to zero.
So this means that at the start of the
training, the cross-attention
contributes exactly nothing.
So the model behaves identically to the
original LLM. And then as the training
proceeds, this gate starts to gradually
open up
and the visual information flows in.
So this is a very principled way to
preserve the pre-trained language
abilities
while slowly learning to incorporate
vision.
Okay, so LaMDA and Flamingo share the
same fundamental assumption. You start
with a pre-trained language model and
then you somehow add vision to it,
right? But there is a third approach
that asks, what if we just throw away
all of that and train everything jointly
from scratch?
And that's the idea behind
native multimodal models. So instead of
adapting language a language model to
handle images, you train a single
unified transformer on all modalities
simultaneously.
So images, audio, video, text, it
doesn't matter. You interleave them in
any order in any combination.
And so the input now is completely
flexible. You can have image image
tokens followed by text, audio,
sorry, audio followed by video
or any arbitrary mix and combination.
And so the The doesn't have uh let's say
primary modality
um
uh with others bolted on. It just sees a
sequence of tokens and learns to reason
over uh all of them jointly.
Um the appeal is obvious
um
um because
uh in principle, this is the bitter
lesson kind of like scale to the extreme
um because there is no architectural
bias toward anyone modality,
uh but obviously is the most expensive
one to train.
Um so most of the current VLMs that you
know are related to one of these three
paradigms we just covered. Um so early
fusion on the left, uh which is
basically a pre-trained LLM plus a
vision adapter,
uh is also the most popular one um in
open-source community with Lava,
PolyGemma, um Gemma 3, and so forth.
Um
the recipe is the same. You just uh swap
in a better vision encoder, better base
LLM, and iterate.
Um then uh late uh fusion in the middle
is a bit of a smaller family,
um and then natively multimodal on the
right is where the big proprietary
models uh are converging, uh like
Gemini, GPT-4.0, GPT-5.
Uh and also increasingly um some of the
um
bigger open-source frontiers like Lama 4
or Qwen 3.5.
Um the trade-off here is essentially
flexibility versus uh preservation
Sorry, uh versus scalability.
Um so early fusion allows uh the richest
cross-modal interaction
uh because the images and text uh mix
freely through uh self-attention, but
then you have to like fine-tune the LLM
and risk degrading its capabilities.
Um
late fusion uh preserves the pre-trained
LLM perfectly, but constrains how vision
and language can interact uh since they
only uh
uh communicate through this um
cross-attention pathways.
Um, and then native multimodal uh,
removes all of the constraints, um, but
you pay the cost of training everything
from scratch.
All right. So, we went from
transformers, um,
for better language translation to LLMs
as general reasoners to VLMs on native
multimodal models that can perceive and
reason about the world.
And every step in this progression was
kind of the same play. Uh, we find the
right the right way to tokenize a new
modality, feed it into the same
architecture, and scale it. Uh,
text and images, uh, then audio and
video, right?
So, now the question is obvious, uh, can
we do the same thing for, uh, robot
actions? Can we tokenize, uh,
actions, throw them into the same
sequence as observations and language,
uh, and train a model that can reason
over all of them jointly?
And this means that we can view
robotics, uh, as a multimodal sequence
prediction problem where we have
language tokens, image tokens, um,
and instead of, uh,
kind of answer text tokens, uh,
action tokens now that can command, uh,
the robot's motors.
Um,
and so,
basically, we can now run the same next,
uh, word, uh, kind of prediction
architecture,
uh, and we can changing anything
fundamental, but just adding like new,
uh, robot action tokens.
And, uh, by using now the attention
mechanism, right? Um, we can now, uh, we
are asking, um, what from my entire
history is relevant,
uh, to what I should be doing right now,
right? So, with the attention, we are
kind of like also, um,
um, looking, um, to solve one of these
like, uh, memory issues that we, uh, uh,
were mentioning in the beginning.
So, how can we tokenize, uh, robot
actions?
Uh, because actions are continuous, um,
and they're not discrete, right? So, the
first way how we can, uh, go around this
is to discretize them.
The first approach used, um, by models
like RT-2 and Open VLA, uh, used a
simple, uh, per dimension per time step
binning scheme.
Um, so the first, that's pretty simple.
First, um, you do quantile
normalization, uh, so for each action
dimension, you compute the first and
99th,
uh, percentile of the action
distribution, uh, across your training
data, and then you clip to those bounds.
Uh, and then by normalizing into the
range minus one to one, uh, using the
quantile bounds, um, the, the
discretization is identical and
comparable across every robot and every
dimension.
RT-2 originally used, uh,
min-max normalization,
but that doesn't work really well with,
uh, outliers,
as, uh, this can result in having to fit
the majority of your distribution into,
let's say, the first three bins, uh, and
then waste the remaining 253 bins, uh,
to represent this one outlier.
Um,
so yeah, so we discretize then each
action dimension, uh, we have, uh, with
the quantiles, and we have normalized
this into minus one and one, um,
and then into, uh, we discretize them
into 256 bins. Uh, and then we finally,
uh, inject this into our LLM vocabulary.
Right? So, now for each, uh, action
dimension, uh, we have like this, uh,
uh, bins. And how do we connect this
with our LLM? Um, one common approach,
uh, is what you can do is you can
override, um, the
uh, least frequent tokens in the
vocabulary. So, let's say if you have
256 action tokens, the least uh, 256
frequent uh,
tokens in in your vocabulary, um, these
are often some
I don't know, weird Chinese symbols or
characters.
Um,
and you can override those now with your
new action tokens to connect um, your
LLM with your action tokens.
And at this point now, the model is just
can do next token prediction with the
same uh, cross-entropy loss and the same
architecture um, as the LLM.
Um, so remember right at the uh, start
of the lecture, we identified these two
problems with the reactive policies,
right? So, the first one was like memory
uh, where like a single observation can
capture the full state of the world. Um,
and then the second was action
smoothness, um, making independent
decisions at every time step produces
this kind of jittery movements, right?
Or incoherent behavior. Um,
and so we uh, kind of addressed memory
through the sequence modeling problem in
the transformers.
Uh, and action chunking is the direct
answer to the smoothness problem. Um, so
the key idea here is that instead of
predicting just the next step, we ask
the model uh, to predict a trajectory of
future actions, so the next K actions.
Um, so the most basic version um, you
can see at the top of the diagram, where
we query the model once, um, it gives us
a chunk, let's say the next four time
steps, um, of the trajectory. We execute
those, uh, which gives us a more fluid
motion,
uh, since uh, all four actions were
planned uh, at the same time or at once
instead of sequentially with a one-step
model.
And after that, we re-query the model to
give us the prediction of the next four
actions, right? And so forth.
Now, um,
if we extend this to longer horizon
chunks,
um,
let's say to accommodate higher
frequency control cuz you're half a
humanoid or something,
uh, let's say we have now a hundred, uh,
like a action chunk of a hundred, um,
that we are predicting.
Um, there is one failure mode where, um,
if we like execute all a hundred actions
before we, uh, re-query the model,
like in the meantime, like in this two
seconds, the the robot is blind, right?
It it doesn't it's not updating
anything, and you know, bad things could
happen in between, right? Uh, that we
didn't account for. Um, and so, one
solution for this is to do temporal
ensembling, uh, which you can see at the
bottom, um, where you re-query your
model at every time step and maintain
multiple overlapping predictions for
every time step.
Um, so for any, uh, given time step, now
you can combine predictions for multiple
queries with, uh, exponentially decaying
weights. And now this gives you the
smoothness benefits of chunking while
staying reactive to new observations at
every step.
And ACT is, um, the paper, uh, from Tony
Zhao, uh, Cheng's, uh, co-founder at
Sunday Robotics, uh, if you remember the
guest lecture from, uh, last week.
Uh, and in this paper, um, they
introduced action chunking from for
Dexter's bimanual control.
The setup is, uh, a bimanual Lo Ha
robot, um, doing 50 hertz, uh, control,
and the model predicts, um, chunks of a
hundred actions at a time. Um, so as the
robot is doing joint control with, uh,
14 degrees of freedom,
um, the model is predicting, um,
1,400 values at every forward pass.
And, uh, this work showed, uh, that
this, uh, action chunking works really
well when you're doing,
uh, really dexterous tasks like this
battery insertion, which requires very
precise coordinated two-arm motions with
very little tolerance for any jitter
or
unsmooth behaviors. Where like a
reactive policy making independent
one-step decisions
at 50 hertz would struggle quite a bit
with doing
these tasks, but
by
having this policy that is planning like
kind of smooth like 2-second chunks of
trajectories, you can see that it can
execute it much more fluidly.
All right. So, we have established that
larger action chunks are helpful to do
smoother high-frequency dexterous
control.
But ACT was not using any LLM and it was
it was not predicting 1,400 values or
tokens auto-regressively.
Um cuz like once you once you want to do
this with a VLA,
this
starts to break down very quickly.
Especially the higher frequency you go
um because the tokens start to look very
similar to each other.
Um so, basically the higher the
frequency you go, the less difference is
there between one step to the next,
right? Like it's such high frequency
that you know, you look at one frame and
the next one and there's like almost no
movement happening in between, right?
And um
the learning signal for an
auto-regressive model comes from the new
information each token provides. And so,
when the tokens are highly correlated,
the marginal information content of the
next token
approaches basically zero. Um so, and
now this means that the model this is
very important can achieve a low
prediction error by simply learning to
copy the previous action token, which
prevents it from learning the actual
dexter skill.
Um and so on on here on the far you can
see how uh performance um starts to
degrade uh once we train VLAs
uh auto-regressively uh at higher uh
control frequencies like 10 Hz or 20 Hz
with this uh naive um
binning uh tokenization scheme that we
just explained.
Um
so the obvious solution
Oh, is to do uh some sort of
compression.
Right? So, instead of um
tokenizing every individual action, you
want to find a more compact
representation like the sub-words in the
original BPE tokenization
that captures the meaningful structure
of the motion.
Right? So, we want to find this
equivalent uh
kind of representation of the sub-words
uh for BPE or the patches for images for
our robot trajectories.
Right? So, um units that are larger than
than than a single time step, but like
smaller um than an entire trajectory.
And so, how can we best compress um
data? Right? Um we we just covered in
LLMs uh we can use BPE
uh which works well for discrete
domains, but as we uh just said like we
have continuous uh data streams uh for
robotics.
Uh we could use like maybe like
VQ-VAEs, um but then this is one more
model and you know, more complexity to
train.
And
um the key idea here uh what you can do
um to get more efficient uh compression
um
um is actually borrowed from signal
processing
um
which is to use the discrete cosine
transform. Um so, if you ever wondered
how um for example, JPEG compression
works, this is essentially it. Um so uh
robot action chunks are smooth
trajectories and smooth signals have
most of their energy in high frequency
Sorry, in the low frequency domains. So,
when you apply DCT to each action
dimension,
you are moving well, moving from the
time domain to the frequency domain.
This gives you a sparse frequency matrix
where most high frequencies are near
zero.
You You condense scale and round these
coefficients,
flatten the matrix with the low
frequency components first, and
then you can run BPE on the actual
resulting integer sequence.
And so, what BPE will do is it will
squash the zeros and merge the frequent
coefficients
combinations, giving you now a compact
sequence of dense tokens that you can
plug directly into your existing
vocabulary.
So, what are the results when we train a
VLA with this approach?
Looking at the left plot,
we can see that our performance
now doesn't break after 5 Hz for an auto
regressive VLA.
We can actually keep improving
performance, and the compression is
doing exactly what it should, right?
It's preserving the information that
matters
and disregarding redundant
high-frequency correlations.
And on the on the right side, you can
see what this compression is is buying
us at test time. Here, we adapted Pi
Zero to do
Sorry,
we adapted Pi Pi Zero to do auto
regression using this
fast organization scheme we just
introduced on top of the PolyGenna
backbone
and compared it against the the Pi zero
from physical intelligence that is using
flow matching instead of auto regression
for action generation. And you can see
that
our model converges five times faster to
the same performance.
This was a collaboration I did with
physical intelligence during my
time at Berkeley.
And
one of the coolest results here is that
we trained a very on the droid data set
that could do zero shot language tasks
in the wild. So we tested it in unseen
kitchens across Berkeley, Stanford, and
University of Washington.
And it worked really well. And also we
were able to do now complex long horizon
by manual manipulation tasks like
laundry folding at 50 hertz. Essentially
now pushing along both axis of general
generality
and dexterity, which typically are in
tension,
right? Because
either you build like kind of specialist
policies like ACT
that are very precise but narrow or
generalist policies like open VLA that
are broad but usually not dexterous
enough for fine manipulation.
And this kind of work
kind of make advances across both.
And
also an output of this work is a good
off-the-shelf tokenizer that's available
on hugging face
that is useful for
like training VLAs. If you want to check
it out.
All right. So to conclude today,
we started with a simple observation.
Reactive policies are fundamentally
limited because one snapshot of the
world can't capture the full state,
right?
And independent per step decisions
produce jittery behavior.
And the fix we addressed in this lecture
is to
reformulate robotics as a sequence
modeling problem.
Um and then we went around building this
this toolkit, right?
Transformers gives us a scalable
architecture for sequence modeling with
01 access to any parts of our history.
Uh scaling those Transformers gives us
LLMs with emergent capabilities.
Um we have seen how to extend them to
vision uh through early fusion, late
fusion, or native multimodal training.
Um this gives
gives us VLMs that can jointly reason
over images and language.
And then
the final step extending all of that to
robot actions, which turns out to be
non-trivial because
naive tokenization breaks at high
control frequency. Uh and you need
compression-based approaches like FAST
to make autoregressive action generation
actually work um at the frequencies the
the robots require.
Um the central insight
running through all the lecture is
really the bitter lesson applied to
robotics. Uh find the right
representation, use a general scalable
architecture, and then let the data
compute do the work.
Um with this, thank you for your
attention.